oh i'm gonna wear this out of this
it's a hoodie i'm gonna fly i hate flies
this is nice i'm a [ __ ] professional
[Music]
this is sona mofscessian and i'm really
excited
because pod swag sent over
a whole box look how white i lift it
full of sona merch
i'm a little overwhelmed i never thought
in my life
i would ever see or
even think anybody would make merch that
has to do with me
but they did potswag did they did it and
it's really exciting and i
got the box i haven't looked at it yet
so i'm just gonna open it up
with all of you watching so you can see
both the excitement the horror
the thrill all the different emotions
that are swirling inside me right now
you can see it in real time this is the
exciting thing so let's do this
i have to unbox all the boxes
this is cool what the hell is this
open oh
my god it's a box oh
cute it's got paper clips
sticky flags and sticky notes and on it
it says
world's worst assistant
i should have opened these before i did
this
you guys oh my god i wish i had the abs
it says team sona oh i don't even need
abs
i just need high-waisted pants i'm going
to wear this
[ __ ] out of this
it's a hoodie it's a nice plush
hoodie it's soft i'm not gonna wear it
tonight because it's
hades outside it is hot as balls
oh my god oh my god
if you guys have an assistant in your
lives
buy them this hat even if they're not
trusty they'll just appreciate it my
head is so big
oh my god check me out
there's so much fun stuff in here
a mug
[Music]
look at that world's worst assistant
and then on the other side it's got
conan o'brien needs a friend
okay team sona in white
i'm gonna make my husband wear this
although he might not be team sona he
might just be team conan
my parents are gonna buy all of this oh
i guess this is men's one is women's and
one is meds
look at that
team sona i'm gonna make you wear this
oh hell yeah this is really nice
there's so much team sona swag in here
it's exciting
and then on the back it says conan
o'brien needs a friend
oh this is big
the world's worst assistant starter kit
what's in this
look at that picture of me and conan
this is
a great depiction of what our
relationship is
i can't tell you how many photos we have
of me just being
supremely annoyed and conan just being
conan
this comes with a
world's worst assistant what is this a
thermos
a water tumbler that's cute
[Music]
uh i had this thing
on my desk it says i'm a
professional i cannot have this out
when kids are in the office because it
has the f
word but
i think that this really conveys a
message that's important which is
i am a [ __ ] professional i
love this
excuses for being late look at this
notepad
this is so cute it's a world's most
worst assistant fancy notebook
that has this thing on it that like
closes it and stuff
look if there's anything even the tissue
paper is cute because it's conan o'brien
needs a front tissue paper
this is the american dream look at this
look at this look at these
look at this world's worth team sona
i can't even tell you guys how excited i
am
my parents will buy all of this if none
of you don't
you can go to podswag.com
team coco so
go there you can buy this if you have an
assistant in your life
or just someone who is the worst
or if you know somebody named sona
there's so many of us out there
no there aren't i think i'm done so
i'm gonna turn this off and finish
cleaning my house
okay